darse otra oportunidad para evitar un
nuevo confinamiento el primer ministro
francés johann castex anunció el viernes
nuevas restricciones ante la epidemia de
kobe 19 pero aplazó cualquier decisión
radical la cuestión es la cuestión del
cierre es legítima dadas las cifras pero
conocemos el fuerte impacto para los
franceses a todos los niveles
gelu por fans de u2
software esta noche consideramos a la
luz de los datos de los últimos días que
aún podemos intentar evitarlo con
versiones del límite y la primera medida
adicional al actual toque de queda será
la prohibición de toda entrada y salida
de francia hacia o desde un país fuera
de la unión europea a partir del domingo
para los países del bloque la entrada
estará condicionada a los resultados de
una prueba pcr esta medida que ya está
en vigor desde el pasado domingo para el
transporte marítimo y aéreo se extiende
ahora al transporte terrestre con castex
ha anunciado también el cierre a partir
del domingo de los centros comerciales
no alimentarios de más de 20.000 metros
cuadrados es decir los que más
aglomeración crean el paro parcial y los
préstamos garantizados por el estado se
seguirán aplicando a las empresas
afectadas aseguró el primer ministro se
anunció además un refuerzo de las
fuerzas policiales con una instrucción
de especial firmeza a quienes defrauden
las normas vigentes de policías de ronda
y se movilizarán policías para controlar
el incumplimiento del toque de queda la
organización de fiestas clandestinas y
la apertura ilegal de restaurantes en
proporciones reforzadas los excesos de
unos pocos no pueden arruinar los
esfuerzos de todos yo no soy el fin de
la reforma
finalmente castex pidió también el
refuerzo del teletrabajo en todas las
empresas en las que sea posible